die Aktionen der klimaaktivisten war
auch Thema bei der noch bis heute
laufenden Innenministerkonferenz in
München und dort begrüße ich jetzt den
Gastgeber den bayerischen Innenminister
Joachim Herrmann schönen guten Morgen
hallo guten Morgen und grüß Gott Herr
Minister Robert Habeck nennt die
selbsternannte letzte Generation eine
radikalisierte Minderheit Gregor Gysi
von den Linken der die Gruppe juristisch
vertritt findet den Protest legitim und
legal und sie
nun legitim und legal ist es ganz
offensichtlich nicht wir haben gerade
gehört das wollen die ja auch gar nicht
es ist in der Tat ein
indiskutables Vorgehen wir wollen den
Klimaschutz weiter voranbringen das ist
dringend notwendig es darf jeder auf
Deutschlands Straßen demonstrieren und
seine Meinungsfreiheit auch entsprechend
wahrnehmen aber wenn man die Freiheit
anderer Menschen dabei krass beschränkt
wenn man gefährliche lebensgefährliche
Situationen wir haben Berliner Flughafen
darauf beschwört dann hat das auch mit
Friedlichkeit wohlgemerkt überhaupt
nichts mehr zu tun und man spürt ja auch
bundesweite auch in den Umfragen dass
eine überwältigende Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung in Deutschland sagt so geht
das nicht die Aktivisten erreichen
dadurch nur mehr Hass und Aggressionen
in der Gesellschaft und keine Zustimmung
zu ihren Anliegen Politik sollte sich
allerdings dann auch nicht von Umfragen
leiten oder treiben lassen in ihrem
Bundesland können Aktivisten einen Monat
lang in präventiv Gehorsam so nennt sich
das genommen werden falls ein Gericht
das anordnet ist das in ihren Augen
verhältnismäßig
das heißt präventiv präventiv Gewahrsam
aber ich habe in den letzten Tagen schon
wiederholt gesagt also ein solcher
Gewahrsam von 30 Tagen muss die absolute
Ausnahme bleiben das wird sicherlich
nicht jetzt häufiger angewandt werden
nach meiner Einschätzung klares das kann
in Einzelfällen mal auch für wie das
zunächst angeordnet war zwei Tage oder
drei Tage der Fall sein um zu verhindern
wenn jemand unmittelbar ankündigt ihr
werde morgen wieder erhebliche
Straftaten begehen und da geht es nicht
nur darum auf der Straße zu kleben
sondern da fanden schwere hauseinbrüche
Frieden aus friedensbrüche statt da sind
eben erhebliche Schäden auch vorsätzlich
mit 10.000 Euro Schäden verursacht
worden das ist kein Spaß und es ist vor
allen Dingen nicht friedlich welche
ständig von friedlichen Protesten
spricht der lügt ganz einfach eine
derartige Auseinandersetzung ist nicht
friedlich präventiv gehorsam ist
allerdings auch ein schöner Versprecher
Herr Minister
forderte jetzt den Verfassungsschutz auf
aktiv zu werden schließen sie sich den
Forderungen des
afd-parteichefs an
nein Forderungen der AFD schließe ich
mich sowieso grundsätzlich nicht an aber
unabhängig davon sind wir uns im Kreis
der Innenminister wir haben da ja
intensiv jetzt hier auch in den letzten
zwei Tagen schon darüber gesprochen wenn
das heute auch noch mal tun wir sehen
uns einig dass solche erheblichen
Straftaten natürlich bekämpft werden
müssen wir müssen uns auch ein Lagebild
insgesamt verschaffen und es ist unsere
Bitte an die Sicherheitsbehörden von
Bund und Ländern hier sie haben
Gesamtüberblick zu verschaffen es gibt
einzelne Hinweise dass wohlgemerkt
einige wenige wohl auch ein Bezug zum
Linksradikalismus haben aber da ist es
wichtig dass die Sicherheitsbehörden
insgesamt sich ein Überblick verschaffen
und die Innenminister möchten dann
möglichst bald eine umfassendes Lagebild
über die Situation in ganz Deutschland
dazu haben ihre Parteifreund Herr
Hermann ex-bundes Verkehrsminister
scheuer forderte ja kürzlich sperrt
diese klimakriminellen einfach weg sie
wissen wir leben in einem Staat mit
Gewaltenteilung ist das
einfach wegsperren csu-parteilinie
nein ganz klar nicht so kann man denke
ich in einer solchen Situation damit der
nicht umgehen man muss auch klar sagen
das Verhalten ist indiskutabel es ist
rücksichtslos gegenüber vielen
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürgern aber
natürlich schützen wir Meinungsfreiheit
schützen wir Demonstrationsfreiheit man
muss diesen Leuten wieder sagen wie das
zum Beispiel frei das für future getan
hat die mit tausenden auf den Straßen in
den letzten Jahren unterwegs waren die
haben auch viele Schlagzeilen bekommen
auch diese Botschaft und müsste sowas
illegales tun man müsste quasi Gewalt
anwenden um Schlagzeilen zu bekommen in
den Medien das ist einfach Unfug frei
das für future hat das anders auch
geschafft und deshalb werden wir aber
den Rechtsstaat auch von solchen Leuten
nicht in Frage stellen lassen sondern da
geht ein gesetzesmäßiges Vorgehen der
Polizei und gegebenenfalls sitze und da
werden dann wenn Straftaten begangen
worden diese Menschen auch entsprechend
angeklagt und da hat sie ersten
Verfahren schon gegeben und weitere
werden sicherlich leider folgen müssen
ganz kurz bei der Konferenz der heute
endet geht es auch um die kritische
Infrastruktur wichtiges Thema und wie
sie vor allen Dingen auch besser
geschützt werden kann wie weit sind Sie
da gekommen können Sie es kurz
zusammenfassen
wir sehen uns einig zum einen dass der
Bund jetzt noch mal ein Gesetz dazu
macht wo manche Dinge klargestellt
zusammengefasst werden wir sind uns
einig darin dass alle entsprechend mehr
Vorsorge treffen müssen das gilt zum
Beispiel für Notstromversorgung an
öffentlich wichtigen Einrichtungen das
gilt für den Ausbau auch der Schutz des
kritische Einrichtungen gegenüber
Cyberangriffen das sind ja ganz
unterschiedliche Baustellen an denen wir
aber gleichzeitig arbeiten müssen und
Bund und Länder sind sich völlig einig
darin da jetzt auch in den nächsten
Monaten weiterhin ein Schwerpunkt der
Arbeit zu liegen
Herr Hermann dann vielen herzlichen Dank
für dieses Gespräch das war der
bayerische Innenminister Gastgeber
aktuell auch der Innenministerkonferenz
alles Gute für Sie
ich danke Ihnen einen schönen Tag danke